lo que estoy por hacer en este vídeo es
algo que quizás la mayoría de ustedes
van a encontrar algo de escondes
desconcertante de hecho la primera vez
que vi a alguien hacer algo así pensé
justamente que era desconcertante así
que solo para repasar los digamos los
antecedentes hemos estado pensando en
nuestro eje espacial y sólo hemos solo
nos hemos enfocado en una dimensión
espacial verdad que a la que estamos
llamando x o x prima según sea el marco
de referencia al cual nos estamos
refiriendo verdad y todo lo que hacemos
en estos ejes lo estamos midiendo en
metros muy bien entonces también estamos
midiendo el tiempo verdad y en principio
pensamos que era algo totalmente
independiente con unidades distintas
verdad y que esas unidades en este caso
serían segundos muy bien pero a medida
que nos adentramos en este mundo de la
relatividad especial vimos que ni el
espacio ni el tiempo son absolutos ya
que los eventos
en el espacio-tiempo voy a escribirlo
así ocurren en el espacio-tiempo y vale
la pena llamarle dios no es así de
rápido espacio-tiempo que porque en
realidad es un único continuo verdad en
realidad es es lo mismo si es así si es
así entonces porque usamos unidades
distintas cabe la pregunta verdad así
que lo que podemos hacer aquí es y es
aquí justo donde parecerá desconcertante
vamos a llamarle ahora a este eje no
vamos a llamarle de prima sino vamos a
llamarle se te prima ya este eje de aquí
le vamos a llamar 7 entonces justo este
eje de aquí será el eje se te prima y
sólo hay que recordar que se es la
velocidad de la luz y voy a aproximar la
digamos por el valor de 3 por 10 a la 8
metros sobre segundo muy bien la
velocidad de la luz es absoluta y no
depende del marco de referencia inercial
en el que no
encontremos entonces si la velocidad de
la luz es sé que es 3 por 10 a la 8
metros sobre segundo entonces este punto
de aquí este punto de aquí ya no se mide
en segundo es verdad porque estamos
multiplicando 3 por 10 a la 8 metros
sobre segundo y multiplicamos después
por un segundo entonces los segundos se
cancelan y ahora este punto de aquí vale
3 por 10 a la 8 metros muy bien entonces
lo que estamos haciendo aquí es ahora
cambiar las unidades de este eje y se
medirán en metros
por ejemplo este punto de aquí ya no
será menos un segundo ahora será menos 3
por 10 a la 8 metros verdad es entonces
ahora estamos midiendo en metros este
punto de aquí ya no será un segundo
ahora será 3 por 10 a la 8 metros y este
punto de acá ya no será menos un segundo
verdad será menos 3 por 10
a la 8 metros muy bien entonces ahora no
sé esto puede parecerte bastante anti
intuitivo verdad porque porque hemos
pensado siempre al tiempo como
fundamentalmente distinto a los metros
verdad de hecho nosotros dejamos gente
en nuestro mundo humano no
experimentamos nada en términos del
espacio-tiempo verdad nosotros sentimos
tan solo que el tiempo avanza digamos
como en una sola dirección verdad
mientras que el espacio es más libre y
podemos movernos hasta digamos hasta en
tres dimensiones es verdad pero pero
ahora pensamos en el espacio-tiempo y
eso hace que tengan las mismas unidades
así que si te sirve puedes puedes ver
este punto como 3 por 10 a la 8 metros
luz que digamos sería el tiempo que le
llevaría la luz a avanzar 3 por 10 a la
entonces análogamente si quisiéramos
ahora por ejemplo dejar todo en términos
de lo que tradicionalmente concebimos
como la dimensión temporal verdad
entonces podemos conservar esto como un
segundo verdad un segundo y en vez de
dejar 3 por 10 a la 8 metros de este
lado tendríamos que poner un segundo luz
que es la distancia que recorre la luz
en lo que nosotros concebimos como un
segundo verdad entonces la ventaja es
que ahora somos consistentes verdad
midiendo diferentes direcciones en el
espacio-tiempo en donde el tiempo y el
espacio no están separados y ahora las
medidas digamos las medidas son en las
mismas unidades muy bien en todas las
direcciones por supuesto lo cual lo cual
será muy conveniente esto esto puede que
te lleve algo de tiempo de asimilar y
quizás digamos haga unos cuantos vídeos
para que te sientas más cómodo con todo
este tipo de ideas pero esto será
conveniente sobre todo cuando tengamos
una métrica en lo que llamaremos el
espacio de minkowski muy bien así que en
realidad esto es porque vamos a operar
en las diferentes dimensiones como si
tuvieran las mismas unidades así que de
verdad te invito a que reflexiones un
poco más sobre todo esto y espero que al
final no te moleste demasiado